Ace was criminally nerfed by the author
of One Piece that's right I said it
because honestly looking at what we know
about Ace he had the potential of
becoming one of the strongest characters
in the entire story however because
Luffy is the main character Ace not only
never got to show his true Powers even
once but he even of course had his life
brutally cut short however let's pretend
for a second that this never happened
and inad instead figure out what might
have happened if Ace had actually
reached his full potential because
picture this 17-year-old Ace becomes a
pirate he gets his fire devil fruit and
starts to make a real name for himself
in the pirate world he literally travels
the entirety of the grand line going
from places like Fishman Island all the
way to wano where he rescued children
from kaido's Castle seriously even
though we barely ever get to see it in
the story this man was the definition of
that guy and before he even turned 20
years old he defeated a warlord and
fought another one for five whole days
but then what happens next in the story
destroyed Aces chances of becoming
pirate king forever because then white
beard showed up beat down Ace and
basically forced the fiery young pirate
onto his own crew now initially without
any doubt this kind of worked out pretty
well for Ace he found the family that he
always wanted and pretty much was happy
all until his death at Marine Fort but
and this is a very big butt Ace joining
whitebeard's crew was basically a death
sentence to his chances at growing
stronger because at this point he didn't
really have to struggle on his own
anymore at all so yeah basically
becoming an underling of the World's
Strongest Man definitely killed A's true
potential but that's all in the past now
because let's imagine that Ace's story
went in a completely new Direction in
the original story Ace fought the for
former warlord and current straw had
jimbe for 5 days before Whitebeard then
showed up to interrupt them so instead
of that let's imagine that Ace actually
defeats jimbe sooner and then he and his
crew sailed away before the yonko ever
arrived to wipe them all out or if that
is too unreasonable for you maybe
Whitebeard does show up and beats down
Ace but instead of inviting him onto the
crew maybe Whitebeard recognizes Ace's
potential and just lets him go and of
course if that happens then Ace would be
absolutely Furious that he couldn't
defeat Whitebeard which means he's now
going to want to get even stronger than
he already did maybe he'll just continue
to train regularly on his own or even
seek out someone to help him reach the
next level either way here's the deal
and so Ace is now around 20 years old
and let's say that after some more time
on his own he's now learned the basics
of armaments and observation hockey
since that was for some reason never
actually confirmed in the story so
technically Ace is now already stronger
than he was in the actual storyline and
so now you might be asking what then
could be Ace's goal since he isn't part
of whitebeard's crew anymore and the
answer I think is quite simple because
if you read the ace novels which you
should absolutely do if you haven't then
you should know that his main goal after
entering the grand line was to defeat
all the Emperors he even burnt down
whitebeard's flag on fisherman Island
when the Spade Pirates passed through on
the way to the new world so everything
that Ace does at this point will be to
grow stronger so that he can actually
take on and defeat the yonko before we
go any further though let's recap where
we are timeline wise at this point
because right now Ace has been a pirate
for around 3 years which is the same
time that Luffy starts his own adventure
as well however there are now some
serious changes to the story since a
didn't join Whitebeard basically the
whole Marine Fort Saga is completely cut
out of the story because that entire
plot line started when Ace insisted on
hunting down Blackbeard because he
betrayed whitebeard's crew by
backstabbing this guy here and so this
time around ace doesn't even know him
and doesn't care so there's no getting
captured by Blackbeard although in this
case Blackbeard might actually end up
going after Luffy a lot harder even more
so than he already did but Luffy already
escaped from Blackbeard the first time
so I'm not going to assume that the
wannabe Emperor would catch Luffy in the
first place here Plus Whitebeard
wouldn't come to Marine Fort as well to
save Luffy anyway so there wouldn't be a
giant battle unless Shanks or Luffy's
father came to save him as well but
we're kind of getting off track here
this video is about Ace not about Luffy
at least yet but what all of this means
is that Whitebeard will still be alive
however that won't last for long because
let's assume that after the years of
extra training Ace finally feels like he
is ready to take on Whitebeard and so
the Spade pip Pirates roll up and
challenge the emperor and while Ace's
crew mates might get completely wiped
out let's be honest I do think that Ace
would be strong enough at this point to
actually take out whitebeards because
remember Whitebeard is still really
really sick and the longer he's in the
story The Worse his condition is about
to get but he is still incredibly
powerful of course and it would be a
legendary fight with whitebeard's trema
powers against AC's supercharged fire
blast and during that fight I can easily
see Whitebeard being reminded of his
clashes with Roger while fighting Ace
which might actually lead to Ace
revealing that he is actually Roger's
son and can you imagine that like that
single fact alone would just completely
blow whitebeard's mind and it is going
to change the rest of Ace's story
forever because let's just imagine that
after an exhausting battle Ace finally
defeats the sick Whitebeard but because
of the respect they gained for each
other Ace spares whitebeard's life
however this is where things turn dark
because just like at Marine Fort in the
scenario I can very easily imagine
Blackbeard swooping in and finishing off
Whitebeard to steal his devil fruit and
since the emperor and ASA just had their
big exhausting battle it makes a lot of
sense to me that Whitebeard and his crew
wouldn't be able to fight them off so I
do see Blackbeard once again killing
Whitebeard and taking his fruit shocking
am I right but I do think one important
thing to add here is that I do think
with his dying breath Whitebeard might
try to inspire Ace to find the one piece
just like he originally did when he did
give his famous the one piece is
realigned during Marine Fort he he might
even go so far as tell a the importance
of what Roger discovered or what AIDS
might need to find the one piece and so
while Ace himself might not really know
exactly what Whitebeard is talking about
here I honestly think that this would
have a major impact on this young pirate
and while he initially might not want to
follow in his Father's Footsteps because
remember he really holds a grudge
against Roger I could see Ace ultimately
deciding to inherit whitebeard's dying
will and kind of take his own approach
to becoming pirate king which honestly
is incredibly ironic as you might say
right now as well because Whitebeard
originally actually wanted Ace to become
pirate king in the actual story as well
but the emperor held Ace back by making
him join his own crew but now that Ace
is actually on his own and still alive
with no hole in him he could very well
be inspired to do exactly what white bit
originally wanted him to do in the first
place so yeah Ace now has a new goal and
a new sworn enemy in Blackbeard but with
Whitebeard out of the picture we do have
to consider who would fill the void in
the emperor ranks and of course it could
just be Blackbeard like normal or it
could also be ace since technically he
was the one who defeated Whitebeard in
the first place and so I would say let's
go with Ace because becoming the next
emperor of the sea because come on it's
just so incredibly cool to imagine Ace
as a yonko and of course the first part
of Ace's new Mission here to become
pirate king is to reach love Tale But
the surprising thing that you have to
remember is that very few people in the
one piece World in general actually know
how to even find directions to this
legendary islands and so to start off
Ace would need to do one of two things
first someone could tell him about the
poneglyphs and how you have to collect
all four Road Pony glyphs to reach L
tail and technically this could be
someone like Marco who has been with
Whitebeard long enough to most likely
know about the poneglyphs Honestly
though that shortcut route kind of feels
a little bit like a cheat so let's go
with the actual way that someone is
supposed to find the final island of the
grand line by reaching loadstar Island
first in case you don't remember this is
the island where Roger and his crew
originally first learned about the
poneglyphs and so let's set Ace on that
very same path and let's say that the
yonko crew of the Spade Pirates will now
sail past all of the other yonko
territories and reach the last official
island of the grand line loadstar and
this is of course where we're going to
have to speculate quite a lot because we
don't actually know yet what is on
loadstar Islands could be a poneglyph
which explains all the other poneglyphs
including the road poneglyph which does
lead to love tail or it could just be
some sort of ancient civilization still
living on loar who helped guide people
to find the one piece and opponent
but whatever the case may be there is of
course one other major problem for Ace
and the Spade Pirates here which is that
even if Ace finds the poneglyphs doesn't
have anyone on his crew who can actually
read and decipher them and so to solve
this problem let's just imagine that Ace
inherited his father's voice of all
things ability which lets Ace somehow
understand what the pony say which
honestly is fairly reasonable to assume
that he would have that ability as well
and although this doesn't really solve
the the problem for good it is good
enough for them to start their Journey
collecting poneglyphs back at the start
of the grand line which now leads me to
personally my favorite part maybe of
this entire scenario which is when Ace
finally reunites with Luffy as a yonko
and boy this is going to be fun because
while they probably wouldn't meet at
Alabaster since the timing is way off
here Ace would still likely visit many
of the same places that Luffy did early
on in his journey as well for example
there was a poneglyph in Alabaster and
another one on Fishman Island So
eventually I would imagine that they
meet up just like they did in the
original story but what's really
interesting here though is that when
these two originally met they had this
interesting conversation about becoming
pirate king obviously that is Luffy's
goal but now Ace himself is on that same
path as well and he has a way bigger
Head Start than his little brother and
so even though these two brothers are
not technically Rivals I just think that
Luffy is nowhere near strong enough at
this point point to become a serious
threat to Ace so Ace would likely just
move on with his journey from here
although there is actually one huge
conflict that will need to be addressed
at some point because even though Ace
has the voice of all things it really
isn't enough to truly translate the road
poneglyphs and reach laugh tale remember
even Roger who did kind of understand
them still needed someone who could
actually read them in order to find the
legendary Island and with Nico Robin
being the only person that we know at
this point in the story who could
possibly read the poneglyphs ace would
surely want her to be on his crew and so
there is a real chance that he could
just try to take her or that Robin
herself might actually want to go with
Ace but for now let's assume that Ace
doesn't know about Robin's ability to
read the poneglyphs or that Robin is
already invested in the straw hats and
so at this point Ace simply moves on for
now and so Ace is well on his way now to
becoming pirate king but this journey is
going to lead him back back to the new
world of course and let's assume that
this takes quite a long time at least a
year or two as the Spade Pirates
continue their journey and it's not like
there's a map or anything that shows
where all the important poneglyphs are
located unless wa maybe maybe there is
actually which would be completely
awesome but then we don't know about
that for sure also keep in mind that
we're missing some major world events
here as well like no Marine Fort as we
said earlier which also means no normal
time skip for the straw head crew
although I could imagine Luffy and his
crew would still need some sort of
training Arc in order to survive in the
new world at any cost but still all of
this means that as Ace is collecting the
poneglyphs and searching for left tail
he would 100% at some point need to
eventually fight big mom and kaido since
both of them possess two of the road
poneglyphs and before that I think it's
very reasonable to assume that ACE also
somehow finds his way to zo and was able
to get a copy of the road poneglyph
there as well I mean I'm not really sure
how that would happen since the Spade
Pirates don't really have a mink on
their crew but who knows maybe they got
a new crew mate along the way who is a
mink or maybe they just use their
connections with their friends in wano
to find someone who can actually take
them there but with that out of the way
he now actually does have to go and face
big mom and kaido and certainly the
Spade Pirates themselves are not all
that powerful yet which would mean that
Ace would need to basically be strong
enough to take on the entire Yono crew
which you know I don't know if Ace is
that strong which means that it makes
perfect sense for Ace to team up with
another pirate who has the same goal oh
I don't know you know maybe someone like
Luffy that's right because by this time
the sted Pirates would most likely have
entered the new world and you might now
think that it is cheating for them to
team up but we already know that Luffy
teamed up with a lot of pirates to take
down kaido so do think it's fair for
Luffy and Ace to work together to defeat
the current emperess plus as you know
Ace already has ties to wano from his
time there early on in his pirate career
so let's just say that instead of Luffy
teaming up with kit and law Ace joins
the party to take down these two yonos
this could either happen separately
first on Huli Island then in wano or the
emperess could team up like they did
during the actual wano Arc and honestly
I don't really think that it matters who
fights who at this point but the
important thing is that with their
combined forces and the people of wano
luff and Ace should be strong enough at
this point to take down kaido and bigma
but the major and unavoidable problem is
coming up next though because because at
this point both Ace and Luffy have three
Road poneglyphs Ace is a legitimate
yonko and Luffy has just awakened his
gear five however Luffy has one really
major advantage over Ace niik Robin
because certainly at this point Ace
would realize that the voice of all
things simply isn't enough to figure out
how to get to love tail he probably
needs to know exactly what the road
poneglyph say so he desperately needs
someone on his crew who can actually
read them now there is this guy to be
fair but I kind of doubt that he would
want to leave wano so that just leaves
one person who can read them and now of
course at this point I would doubt that
Robin would want to go with Ace but if
Ace truly is determined to become pirate
king then he will stop at nothing to
fulfill his goal which ultimately means
that these two Crews will have to clash
at some point which yeah I know is
shocking but that's what it's going to
take to become pirate king it even might
happen between Luffy and Shanks if we're
being honest and I can just imagine that
Luffy and a going all out against each
other is a thing that they would do Aces
Flames would be extremely powerful at
this point he's basically like a fullon
fire god but Luffy also now has his gear
five powers which as we've seen can let
him take out even the strongest of
characters so it's really hard to say
how a battle of the sort would go but in
the end I do seriously doubt that they
would go all the way to killing each
other I mean they are brothers of course
in fact let's be real they might even
decide to end this fight in one of the
most controversial ways possible let me
explain if you go back to the arc just
after skypia we were introduced to the
concept of the Davey back fight now this
is a real pirate competition in the one
piece world where pirate Crews can
challenge each other in order to steal
members from each other's Crews and yeah
as silly as that Arc actually was it
really does seem like Pirates take this
extremely seriously and there's even
speculation that the Legendary Pirate
roxc used the Davy back fight in order
to gather his impressive crew so anyways
you might be wondering now what exactly
is even a Davy back fight in case you
skip that Arc which you know no shame on
that well again we've only seen this one
in the story but it did involve a
three-stage competition first a boat
race around an island a game called
groggy ring which is kind of like soccer
except that one player in each team is
the actual ball and finally a one-on-one
duel where the person who gets knocked
out of the ring first loses and of
course the winner of these events gets
to take members from the other person's
crew now we weren't sure if this is how
every single day the back fight actually
works since we've only seen one in the
entire story but for the sake of this
video Let's assume that Ace and the
Spade Pirates would win this event in
the end and NCO Robin is forced to join
Ace's crew in fact we could even go as
far as to say that the entire straw hats
are forced to join the Spade Pirates but
I'm not actually sure if Luffy would
ever be willing to work under someone
else even his brother so for now let's
just assume that Robin is the only one
that joins the Spade Pirates and that
means that Ace now has a clear path
towards becoming pirate king all he has
to do is to find the last fourth
poneglyph which is likely being
protected by the emperor Shanks and the
Giants and elb and then make his way to
love tale and while that's no easy task
we do know that Ace already knows Shanks
so while I don't think that Shanks would
just give Ace the road poneglyph if we
can imagine that Luffy would somehow
obtain it from Elba then the same
applies to Ace I think there 's just one
other big big problem though here
because in all this time we still have
the massive threat of Blackbeard who
will very likely be AC's final challenge
before becoming pirate king but with all
that's gone on in the story plus AC's
extra motivation to take down the person
who killed Whitebeard I just have to
imagine that Ace as Roger son would come
out on top here fairly convincingly
which just goes to show how much insane
potential firefist a the potential
future pirate king actually had in the
story although this also brings up
another character with insanely untapped
potential because if you've ever thought
that it is criminally unfair that Luffy
and Zoro get all the attention from the
straw hats you're not alone because
Sanji is just as deserving as the other
two so to Hype him up a little bit more
even I figured out the perfect devil
fruit to make Sanji into a true God tier
level fighter and you can watch that
video right here Shanks for watching and
I hopefully see you in the next one